2020 marque les cinq ans de la mise en
application de la loi morange qui a
rendu obligatoire l'installation de
détecteurs de fumée dans les lieux
d'habitation
son nom vient de l'un des deux
parlementaires qui a proposé le texte de
loi
l'ancien député de la 6e circonscription
des yvelines pierre morange est
actuellement maire de chambourcy
le but éviter des événements dramatiques
à cause des incendies
c'est d'ailleurs un drame qui a conduit
les deux députés a proposé le texte de
loi dans la nuit du 20 avril 2002
josiane beaud sicot perd sa fille julia
alors âgée de 17 ans dans l'incendié
d'un pavillon achats venait le député
des yvelines se souvient je dirais que
ce devrait être la loi boïko josiane
beaud chico qui est une mère de famille
sud une mère courage j'avais été tout à
la fois impressionné par la générosité
le courage de cette femme qui a fait su
dépasser sa douleur quand en faire un
combat le combat de sa vie au profit de
tous et sur le thème un peu de plus
jamais ça le 8 mars 2015 le combat de
cette mère de famille abouti à la loi
morange qui prévoit l'obligation d'au
moins un détecteur de fumée dans chaque
logement le propriétaire du bien en a la
charge
dans le cas d'une location l'entretien
comme le changement des piles par
exemple c'est le locataire qui doit s'en
acquitter mais selon l'ancien
parlementaire yvelinois cette obligation
ne serait pas respecter à 100% de taux
d'équipement tourner aux alentours du
quelques 65 % dit on est bien le chemin
reste encore à parcourir et je rappelle
que la proposition de loi que j'avais
déposé ça n'était pas au propriétaire
donc d'avoir la responsabilité la mise
en oeuvre ce détecteur autonome de fumée
c'était aux locataires ce placement à
l'occupant d'un bien bien qu'il ne soit
plus aux affaires parlementaires pierre
morange aimerait tout de même que la loi
évolue pour passer d'environ 65% à 100%
d'équipement des logements le minimum
c'est de lier la police d'assurance
sinistre incendie à la présentation de
la facture d'acquisition du dispositif
si déjà on avait cela alors il y aurait
toujours le sujet de l'entretien le
changement des piles ainsi de suite
mais si déjà il y avait cet élément là
ou feraient un grand bond en avant grâce
à cette loi morange le dispositif de
détecteurs de fumée aurait permis de
réduire de 25 % par an la mortalité due
aux incendies domestiques